so we've got an infinite series here
negative 1 to the n plus 1 over the
square root of n i always like to
visualize this a little bit more expand
it out so when n equals 1 the first term
is negative 1 to the second power so
it's going to be positive it's going to
be 1 over 1. so it's 1. we go minus 1
over the square root of 2
plus 1 over the square root of 3 minus 1
over the square root of 4 and then plus
minus and we just go on and on and on
forever
now when we've looked at convergence
tests for infinite series we saw things
like this this passes the alternating
series test and so we know that this
converges let's say it converges to some
value s
but what we're concerned about in this
video is not whether or not this
converges but estimating what this
actually converges to we know that we
can estimate this by taking a partial
sum
let's say s sub k this is the first k
terms right over here and then you're
going to have a remainder so plus
the remainder
after you've taken the first k term so
this actually starts with the k plus
first term
and so what i'm concerned about or what
i want to figure out is how many what's
the minimum number of terms what's the
minimum k here
so that my remainder so that the
absolute value of my remainder is less
than or equal to 0.001
and i encourage you to pause the video
based on what we've seen in previous
alternating series estimation situations
to see if you can figure this out
all right i'm assuming you've had a go
at it so let's just remind ourselves
what r sub k looks like
so r sub k
r sub k
is going to be it's going to start with
the k plus first term so it's going to
be negative 1
k plus 1 plus 1 so it's negative 1 to
the k plus 2
over the square root of k
of k plus k plus 1
k plus 1
and then the next term
i could just write plus
negative 1 to the k plus 3
over the square root of k plus 2 and
it's just going to go on and on and on
like that
now what we know already or what we've
seen an example of and we'll verify or
at least get a conceptual verification
for us at the end of this video is
well this the this the absolute value of
this entire sum the absolute value of
this entire sum
is going to be less than the absolute
value of the first term so let me write
that down the absolute value of this
entire sum of this entire remainder
r sub k
and since you know some people refer
this to as kind of the alternating
series remainder property or whatever
you want to call it but the absolute
value of this entire thing is going to
be less than or equal to the absolute
value
of the first term negative 1
to the k plus 2
over the square root
of k plus one and of course we want that
to be less than one thousandth
so less than that needs to be less than
or equal to zero point zero zero one
and so now this set up right over here
inspires you i once again encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can
figure out what is the minimum k what is
the minimum k that satisfies this
inequality
well once again i'm assuming you've had
to go through go at it and the the key
realization here is that this negative 1
to the k plus 2 this makes this whole
thing either positive or negative the
denominator is going to be positive for
well it's definitely going to be
positive for all the case frankly for
which this the principal root is going
to be defined but we obviously these are
all positive k's as well so the
numerator here just flips the sign we we
flip between negative one or positive
one negative one or positive one but if
we take the absolute value then we know
where whatever is whether it's negative
or positive it's going to end up being
positive so this first this thing on the
left hand side
this thing on the left hand side that's
the same thing as just 1 over the square
root of k
the square root of k plus 1 and then
that's going to be less than or equal to
that needs to be less than or equal to
0.001
and now we just have to solve we have to
just solve this inequality find out
which k's satisfy this inequality and so
let's see we can multiply both sides by
the square root of k plus one
so square root of k
plus one so we can get this out of the
denominator
and let's actually multiply both sides
times a thousand because this is a
thousandth and so we'll end up with a
one on the right hand side so times a
thousand
times
a thousand and what we're going to be
left with is these cancel out on the
left hand side
we don't have to flip the sign because
we just multiplied by positive things
so we have a thousand
is less than or equal to the square root
of k plus one we could square both sides
and we get one million
one million
is less than or equal to
k plus one
and so
and then we can just subtract one from
both sides and we have nine hundred
ninety nine thousand nine hundred ninety
nine is going to be less than or equal
to k
so k
just has to be greater than or equal to
999 9999 and remember we want the
smallest k that satisfies these
conditions so the smallest gift case to
be greater than or equal to this the
smallest k that satisfies this is k is
equal to 999
99999 so let's write that down
so the smallest k for which this is true
is going to be k is equal to 999
900 and
now let's convince ourselves that that
remainder that the absolute value of the
remainder is definitely going to be less
is is definitely if we if if our k if we
take the partial sum of the first 999
999 terms that this remainder is
actually going to be less than this i'm
telling you so far we've just kind of
worked from the premise that it will be
but let's actually let's actually look
at that and and feel good about it and
once again i encourage you to pause the
video and try it on your own
so let's just rewrite this again but i'm
going to expand out r sub k
so we're saying that it's all going to
converge to s
and we're going to take the partial sum
the partial sum of the first 999
999 terms and we're claiming that this
is going to be within one thousandth of
this right over here
so this is going to be plus
and so the first term is going to be the
of the remainder of r sub k is going to
be our millionth is going to be our
millionth uh our millionth of term
and so
the millionth term we just remind
ourselves it's going to be negative 1 to
the million and 1 power so negative 1 to
the millionth and 1 power that's going
to be a negative that's going to be
negative 1 because that's an odd number
so it's going to be negative 1 over the
square root of a million so actually let
me do it like this so it's going to be
it's going to be minus 1 over the square
root of a million
a million and then the next term is
going to be plus
1 over the square root of a million
a million and one and it's positive now
because this is going to be the mill to
the million and negative one to the
million and a million and two second
power
and then it's going to be
minus
one over
the square root of one million
one million and two
and then plus
plus i'll just do two more terms one
over
the square root
of a million
a million and three and then minus one
over
the square root
of
a million
and four and then plus minus it just
keeps going on and on on and on and on
forever now i want to convince ourselves
that this thing is going to be this the
absolute value of this thing is going to
be less than one thousandth it's going
to be essentially less than the absolute
value of this first term
so how do we think about it so this
first term we already know this right
over here is
this first term right over here is
negative
0.001 because it's 1 over
1000 and it's going to have this
negative right over here
now the first thing we could realize if
we just if we just put parentheses like
this
if we just put parentheses like this
we see that this is going to be positive
this term is larger than this term this
term is larger than this term we could
keep going
so
we're going to have we're start we we're
we're
the remainder kind of starts at negative
one thousandth and then it just adds a
bunch of positive terms so it's not
going to get any more negative than this
so we know that the remainder can't get
more negative than this but let's also
verify that it can't you know get for
get more than a positive thousandth
either and the way that we can do that
is to just
look at the parentheses in a different
way if we do it this way
if we do it this way
that's going to be this is going to be a
negative value
this right over here is going to be a
negative value and we can just keep so
we could say plus that
plus that and so we're going to have a
bunch of negative values together so
just like that we by really looking at
the parentheses a little bit differently
we're able to say this is definitely
going to be negative this remainder is
definitely going to be a negative value
but it can't be any more negative than
our first term so that tells us that our
remainder is not going to get any fur is
not going to be any more can't we get
any the absolute value of the remainder
can't get any larger than 1 000. we're
not gonna as we add more and more and
more terms here we're not going to get
any further away from
from the actual sum
than we were then then the i guess we
could say then then the first term